I says I can't do it right either yeah
that's why the should not squeeze the
juice out of the ground in containers
placed properly or you come to it No
let's check the other rooms let's check
what a great pass to see is this where
we came from yeah
oh [ __ ]
here's the chunks of coal at night it's
a laboratory might be accessible
oh yeah it is but
oh [ __ ] this is Oakland
this was not open before
and this looks creepy
yeah
drain and pipe
blood cannot be reached find a way to
lower the vessel let's connect those two
words well and nice
sweet so that's why we couldn't do it
right now because we need the last jar
of blood for some reason yeah should we
shake in there I don't really don't
wanna finish it won't budge yes
okay so puzzle solved AIESEC nada
[ __ ] shut up I am hurry
an [ __ ] I'm not gonna save him just
because of that
get back in here the laboratory and now
we can squeeze the poison ivy hopefully
the blood needs to be purified I guess
you do it yes we boil it yeah
sweets it's a blood becomes white
in complete tonic seriously this blood
become white when you boil it
nope what's up in here why did I do that
what am I supposed to place in there the
war parts no guitar get the part yes no
it didn't work
I want it back I want to choose it on
left fun No
I thought we were done with this stupid
puzzle
it's gotta be the toilet our
what am i doing
seriously
once that you have a bit left corner
it's my laner you know
maybe you have to go back to this change
yeah probably
goddamnit
[ __ ]
not going in there
maybe there's a hint wait
oh oh yeah
shut up
hate you
I'll give a nice voice he sounds like a
polite guy actually but he has an accent
in oh we need that bone saw that sounds
nice
I can't tell leaves that for freeing
heck yeah that's true oh [ __ ]
but sawing off his bones [ __ ] you're
standing on the box
so I change but it was a bone saw
haven't seen soul yeah but bones okay
he used to change narrating or can you
maybe you can I don't know
oh [ __ ]
confused peuta is confused
okay I'm gonna use it Donny
but it needs a tonic and then that's
what we're preparing so we are gonna
save him actually sir but
maybe we can use it for something else
as well
no probably not
I'm out of ideas to be honest
maybe miss something probably
but like where
we came from this really creep this
place may be a case where we found a
pieces yeah let's go there
no not there
wait we can't go in here I think oh [ __ ]
I hate that
you cannot before
yeah we've been here the right there is
Oh fuc
but-but-but
I mean I guess we could check it out
yeah you need to find something you my
slave of my choice every nice
is there any way you could like make
your fan sound any less one your fan
from your computer sounds a lot oh
that's true
I guess it's alright but
this is where he killed me I can hear
him moan
and I can hear scary music it's two
things I don't like where I see
[ __ ]
I guess we got to go here
did we walk in here before
I thought I saw him [ __ ] he's behind me
he's behind me oh [ __ ] he's here like me
[Applause]
Daniel oh [ __ ]
oh he's breaking through the door oh
hush not going in there oh my god yeah
the music is so I think the worst part
is I actually think that's where we're
gonna go
what do you think yeah I'm reading here
and you need a bone with most mucus are
you [ __ ] it's fine I don't care I
just want to finish this a bone with
mucus what [ __ ] is that
mucus puke is
[ __ ] hate the mall sir
seriously
we should flat
so it's the bone we're gonna put in that
thing to obtain the stain poem you'll
have to visit the crystal cell block
before chancel and the center-right
staircase you will find a piece of meat
on the table they're collected and go to
the left area with the torture chamber
you know collage Group B green room with
three doors and the vertical spiral
staircase yeah for that room is some
other room to your right with a well I'm
not going there I'm buying a piece of
meat with the rope from the well leave
her the rope well something on earth or
will we eat meat down there wait alright
it's separating I can't understand a
thing did you say the torture room
because we can't enter the torture room
obtained obtained bone units based
prison cell block you need to find a
piece of meat see you know oh wait no
there's nothing here dude
go to the transept to the room where the
man was torn in half it should be great
under there open it up combine the
string rope with your glass yeah well no
but I can't go back you know oh [ __ ] I
hate you
maybe there's a way to distract the
monster you can try that I hope it's not
outside now
can't you check where I am I have all
all the pieces look what like I'm
missing
and then where I can find that thing
that I'm missing okay I'm gonna eat now
okay thanks I'm gonna go visit the
creepy monster again it's why the [ __ ]
not I hope it's not there twice I'd be
horrible you need to get to the prison
block so oh [ __ ] I've already been there
our fight is before the chancel we can
send the right staircase that spiral
stair that you know went up in there
dude easy now is he there
I went here before and the monster was
here
there's something here yeah I haven't
read that
I don't believe I have become one of the
girls escaped like chased off that's a
good a because you were supposed to my
own but to kill an innocent to save
myself
oh that's why you wanted to forget
murderer I see
we're murderer
there's got to be something here
I'm pretty sure we're gonna go down
there and I'm pretty sure the monsters
gonna be there yeah good no it's not
[ __ ] good
I hear machinery
oh this is new this this gate wasn't
open before